[Musik]
die Truppe kann sich darauf verlassen
dass ich mich wann immer es nötig ist
vor sie stellen werde ich will die
Bundeswehr stark machen für die Zeit die
vor uns liegt ich bin man da zeugt dass
das jemand ist der mit der Truppe kann
und den die Soldaten und Soldaten sehr
mögen werden und ich bin sehr dankbar
dass er ja gesagt hat und wir freuen uns
auf die gute Zusammenarbeit mit dem
Minister Boris Pistorius
guten Abend willkommen zu einem kurzen
zdf-spezial
es ist Tag eins nach Lambrecht neuer
Verteidigungsminister wird Boris
Pistorius übernimmt eine Bundeswehr die
viele Insider als bedingt einsatzbereit
bezeichnen in extrem schwieriger Zeit
Sie schnell und effektiv fit zu machen
nicht zuletzt mit den 100 Milliarden aus
dem sogenannten Sondervermögen wird
seine Hauptaufgabe sein was qualifiziert
ihn was bringt der langjährige
Innenminister aus Niedersachsen dafür
mit Klaus Brodbeck stellt uns Boris
Pistorius vor
er muss es nun richten Boris Pistorius
62 noch Innenminister von Niedersachsen
übernimmt in schwierigen Zeiten das wohl
schwierigste Berliner Ministerium
überhaupt die Aufgaben die vor der
Truppe liegen sind gewaltig
ich werde deshalb meine Dienstgeschäfte
unmittelbar nach der Vereidigung am
Donnerstag aufnehmen und mich mit dem
Ministerium der Bundeswehr Führung und
natürlich auch den Parlamentarier und
den parlamentaren austauschen
mir ist bei all dem und das hat meine
Arbeit hier auch im Innenministerium in
Niedersachsen stets geprägt wichtig der
enge und vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit
mit den Menschen die mir in diesem Amt
anvertraut sein werden mit den Soldaten
und mit den Soldaten historius gilt das
Sicherheitsexperte auch über die
Innenpolitik hinaus als
durchsetzungsstarker Freund klarer Worte
und jetzt wohl auch als Retter des
Kanzlers nach Christine lambrechts
verstolpertem Abgang er ist nicht nur
ein Freund und ein guter Politiker
sondern auch jemand der über sehr sehr
viele Erfahrungen in der
Sicherheitspolitik verfügt der sehr
offen und eng auch in seiner bisherigen
Funktion mit der Bundeswehr
zusammengearbeitet hat und der auch die
Kraft und Ruhe besitzt die man für eine
so große Aufgabe angesichts der jetzigen
Zeiten Wände braucht Anfang der 80er
leistete der Jurist aus Osnabrück seinen
Wehrdienst ein bisschen also kennt der
neue die Truppe auch von innen und unten
was pistori ist einer der ein weites
großes Herz hat für die Bundeswehr dem
die Bundeswehr vertrauen kann und auf
die die Bundeswehr sich verlassen kann
die Union bietet Pistorius Unterstützung
an die Grünen stört das künftig Männer
im Kabinett die Mehrheit bilden es ist
in der gegenwärtigen Lage mit Krieg in
Europa vielleicht das wichtigste Amt das
in der
Bundesregierung nach dem Bundeskanzler
ausgeübt wird für uns Grüne ist das
weiterhin Selbstverständnis und auch
selbstverständlich dass wir die Hälfte
an Frauen mindestens in Führungsposition
haben Donnerstag wird Boris Pistorius
vereidigt blitzt ins neue Amt
in Berlin begrüße ich die
SPD-Vorsitzende Saskia esken guten Abend
guten Abend sie waren ja direkt
beteiligt an den findungsgesprächen was
hat denn am Ende den Ausschlag gegeben
für Pistorius
lassen Sie mich zunächst mal sagen dass
ich Frau Ministerin Christine Lamprecht
sehr dankbar bin für ihre Arbeit im
vergangenen Jahr in den vergangenen
Jahren muss man sagen sie hat wirklich
viele geleistet für dieses Land auch für
unsere Partei und ich kann Ihnen noch
einen Dank aussprechen wo ist historisch
ist ein herausragender
Sicherheitspolitiker der SPD ich bin
sehr glücklich dass wir diese gute
Entscheidung treffen konnten das war ja
ein guter Entscheidung sie sagen sie es
war ja ein erklärtes Ziel von Kanzler
Scholz Parität im Kabinett zu haben also
genauso viele Ministerinnen Minister das
ist jetzt nicht mehr so weil es nicht
mehr so wichtig ist
na die gleiche Teilhabe von Frauen und
Männern vor allem auch an den
Schaltstellen der Macht in unserer
Partei in der Fraktion in den Vorständen
und natürlich auch im Kabinett war immer
und ist immer und bleibt auch ein
wichtiges Ziel für die SPD an dieser
Stelle haben jetzt andere Kriterien eine
größere Rolle gespielt deswegen haben
wir diese Entscheidung getroffen das
bedeutet aber nicht dass wir das Ziel
der Parität weiterhin nicht verfolgen
Kritiker aus Opposition und auch aus der
Bundeswehr sprechen von einem verlorenen
Jahr unter Verteidigungsministerin
Lambrecht auch wenn sie ja gerade noch
mal gedankt haben was muss denn jetzt
besser werden
nach 16 Jahren auch unionsgeführter
Verteidigungspolitik müssen wir sagen
dass es Ministerium dass die Bundeswehr
auch in einem schlechten Zustand sind
und dass sie jetzt dringend schon im
vergangenen Jahr alle auch alles
Augenmerk benötigt haben gebraucht haben
nicht nur ein Sondervermögen und mehr
Geld sondern vor allem auch eine
Stärkung der Struktur eine Verbesserung
der Strukturen im Beschaffungswesen in
vielen anderen Dingen da wird Boris
pistorie jetzt auch natürlich mit seiner
langjährigen Erfahrung der Führung eines
Ministeriums ganz genau hinschauen und
die richtigen Entscheidungen treffen die
Zeit drängt auch was sie Unterstützung
der Ukraine betrifft wo kann denn der
neue Verteidigungsminister da Akzente
setzen und schneller Erfolge vorzeigen
insbesondere kommt es da auf die bessere
Zusammenarbeit auch mit der Industrie an
dass wir eben sowohl die Ausstattung der
Bundeswehr denn auch da haben wir ja
große Menge um die Landes- und
bündnisverteidigung wiederherzustellen
und Fähigkeiten herzustellen die wir
lange vernachlässigt haben als auch eben
die Unterstützung der Ukraine da
brauchen wir eine gut funktionierende
Zusammenarbeit auch mit der
Rüstungsindustrie auch da hat es in der
Vergangenheit gemangelt und da müssen
wir besser werden vielen Dank für das
Gespräch Frau esken sehr gerne
Boris Pistorius steht vor einem
Kaltstart ins Amt Schonzeit Fehlanzeige
am Donnerstag soll er vereidigt werden
am gleichen Tag wird
US-Verteidigungsminister Ortsteil in
Berlin erwartet und am Freitag treffen
sich die 30 NATO-Staaten und Partner auf
der Militärbasis Ramstein um über
weitere Militärhilfen für die Ukraine zu
beraten was kann Deutschland leisten und
wo liegen die großen Baustellen der
Bundeswehr Martin Honecker
liefern oder nicht liefern die Frage
nach den Kampfpanzern hat die
Bundesregierung bisher verneint aber der
internationale Druck ist groß zu den
größten Herausforderungen für den neuen
Verteidigungsminister gehört die
Unterstützung der Ukraine schon in drei
Tagen treffen sich die westlichen
Verbündeten auf dem
US-Luftwaffenstützpunkt in Ramstein ein
mutmaßliches Hauptthema die Lieferung
des deutschen Kampfpanzers Leopard 2
davon hat Deutschland noch etwa 300 aber
nicht alle sind einsatzbereit die
Rüstungsindustrie hat keine neuen auf
Lager denn ihr ist das gesetzliche
untersagt Panzer für die Lagerhaltung zu
produzieren Neubestellungen dauern zwei
bis drei Jahre
etwa 20 Länder nutzen den Leopard 2 und
könnten einige weitergeben Polen
beliefern Spanien Finnland wäre auch
bereit weil die Panzer aber aus
deutscher Produktion stammen muss
Deutschland der Weitergabe zustimmen
eigene Kampfpanzer abzugeben ein Problem
auch vor dem Hintergrund der Landes und
bünd Verteidigung der Wehrhaftigkeit
schickt Deutschland Kampfpanzer in die
Ukraine fehlen die für die Aufgaben der
Bundeswehr und seit dem 1 Januar ist
noch eine große dazugekommen
2023 führt Deutschland die schnelle
Eingreiftruppe der NATO an die
sogenannte Speerspitze
da tun ausrüstungsmängel besonders weh
es mangelt an Munition der Puma
Schützenpanzer macht Probleme und
Schutzausrüstungen gibt es auch nicht
für alle Soldaten helfen soll da das 100
Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr aber die Modernisierung steht
erst am Beginn bisher wurden Verträge
über gut 10 Milliarden Euro geschlossen
die Aufrüstung hatte Kanzler Scholz aber
schon vor knapp einem Jahr verkündet
und dann wäre dann noch der Rückzug aus
Mali noch sind mehr als 1000 Soldaten im
Rahmen der UN stabilisierungsmission
minusma im westafrikanischen Mali
eingesetzt aber das dortige Militär
hatte geputscht und setzt russische
Wagner Sydney ein der Rückzug ist auch
deshalb beschlossene Sache und soll bis
Mai 2024 geordnet abgeschlossen werden
und zugeschaltet aus Hamburg ist der
Militärexperte Sönke nights der guten
Abend schönen guten Abend
was müsste auf Pistorius to do Liste
jetzt ganz oben stehen
naja es geht ja letztlich um die
Neugründung der Streitkräfte so müssen
es glaube ich formulieren und diese
Neugründung wird nur gelingen wenn man
oder nur mit einer großen Reform der
Strukturen und das Beschaffungswesens
gelingen das ist glaube ich zunächst das
was er angehen muss wie würden Sie denn
das Erbe beschreiben dass der neue
Verteidigungsminister jetzt antritt
das ist in der Tat ein schwieriges Erbe
Frau esken hat es schon gesprochen
angesprochen wir haben viele viele
Jahrzehnte müssen wir ja sagen
unzureichender Investitionen in die
Bundeswehr übrigens nicht nur aufgrund
der SPD der CDU-Politik sondern auch
aufgrund der SPD die sehr viel blockiert
hat der liegt viel viel im Hagen wir
haben uns auf völlig anderes Szenarien
ausgerichtet und natürlich ist im
letzten Jahr einfach zu wenig passiert
die Bundeswehr fit zu machen ist
offenbar ja keine Kleinigkeit über
welche Zeiträume reden wir denn da
naja wenn jetzt alle Weichen richtig
gestellt werden ist das ein einen
Zeitraum von etwa 15 Jahren das müssen
wir veranschlagen das ist mein klares
Wort und das betrifft dann auch mehr als
nur einen Verteidigungsminister aller
Voraussicht nach aber bleiben wir noch
mal in dieser Woche schauen auf den
Freitag da wird in Ramstein über die
weitere militärische Unterstützung der
Ukraine beraten die sie zweifellos
braucht was muss Deutschland jetzt
schnell leisten also ich glaube
Deutschland kann die Lieferung von
Leopard 2 Kampfpanzern auch aus
politischen Gründen kaum blockieren die
Deutschen sollten da vorangehen sie
sollten jetzt sagen ein europäischen
Verbund organisieren denn eins ist klar
die Ukraine ist ein wirklich in einer
militärisch schwierigen Lage manche
reden ja irgendwie von von Siegen der
Ukraine ich würde eher das ein bisschen
kritischer sehen ähm
sagen es geht jetzt darum dass die
Ukraine nicht verliert dass die Ukraine
gestärkt wird in ihrer Verteidigung und
dazu können Kampfpanzer ein Beitrag
leisten nicht und die Deutschen müssen
einfach langfristig denken der Krieg
wird lange weiter weitergeben wie kann
man die Unterstützung der Ukraine
langfristig sicherstellen und dazu muss
auch in Deutschland endlich die
Rüstungsproduktion angeworfen werden
rechnen Sie damit einer größeren
Frühlingsoffensive der Russen ja das
also keiner von uns der Wohnung auf Sie
oder ich können sagen was in den
nächsten vier Wochen passiert das ist so
ein bisschen raten aber in der Tat ist
es so dass einige russische Verbände die
wir Orten könnten verschwinden und ich
würde vermuten dass die Russen eine
Frühjahrsoffensive vorbereiten und
deswegen ist es wichtig jetzt auch die
Ukraine zu stärken ähm damit sie
weiterhin ihr Land verteidigen können
vielen Dank für das Gespräch so sehr
gerne
es ist ein dickes Brett dass der neue
Verteidigungsminister dazu bohren hat
ein schwerfälliger Apparat mit Reform
Stau ein Krieg vor der Haustür und alles
unter gehörigen Zeitdruck der aber kann
durchaus hilfreich sein wenn es etwa
darum geht Entscheidungen in der
Bundesregierung durchzusetzen
das war unser zdf-spezial vielen Dank
für Ihr Interesse hier geht es gleich
weiter mit den Rosenheim-Cops einen
schönen Abend und auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]